the March for Life tens of thousands of
people right now are marching on
Washington DC for the 45th annual March
for Life never heard of it you're not
alone even many conservatives don't
really know anything about it because
the mainstream media generally black the
event out which is really incredible by
the way as the March for Life is the
longest continual protest in American
history
they've been marching ever since the
Supreme Court's decision in roe v wade
that made up a constitutional right to
abortion you know you know that thing
with the framers were so concerned about
abortion
giveme abortion or give me death I
forget exactly which article that right
to abortion is in but if you read the
Constitution very very closely and then
you invent that right out of whole cloth
you should find it pro-life supporters
have come in from all over the country
and their efforts have not been in vain
five years ago in 2013 the number of
annual abortions fell below 1 million
for the first time in 40 years and that
number has slowly continued to drop of
course that means there are still
roughly 1 million babies killed in the
womb each year with maniacal ghouls like
Cecile Richards at Planned Parenthood
snuffing out a third of them Planned
Parenthood alone has killed more than 7
million babies in the womb since roe v--
wade and as the Center for medical
progress expose showed us Planned
Parenthood has profited marvelously by
selling babies body parts on the black
market to the highest bidder
since roe v-- wade well over 60 million
abortions have occurred in the united
states to put that in perspective that's
the total population of South Carolina
Louisiana Kentucky Oregon Oklahoma
Connecticut Iowa Mississippi Arkansas
Utah Kansas Nevada New Mexico Nebraska
West Virginia Idaho Hawaii Maine New
Hampshire Rhode Island Montana Delaware
South Dakota Alaska North Dakota
Washington DC Vermont and Wyoming
combined today as many people identify
as pro-life as pro-choice up
tremendously over the past four decades
despite the constant slew of
pro-abortion propaganda from the
mainstream media and Hollywood cynical
politicians scare monger they say that
without abortion before roe v-- wade
without roe v-- wade thousands of women
would die each year from back-alley
abortions from coathanger abortions the
former head of the National Abortion
Rights Action League Bernard Nathanson
has since admitted that he and his
pro-abortion conspirators completely
invented that number it was totally made
up it's a total lie in reality by 1972
the year before a roe v-- wade when
abortion was still illegal in the
majority of the country the actual
number of women who died from illegal
abortions was 39 not 39 thousand not
3939 the wilder statistic is that that
same year 24 women died from legal
abortions despite legal abortion only
existing in a small percentage of states
the mass slaughter has taken a
disproportionate toll on racial
minorities in New York City more black
babies are aborted than born this is no
coincidence
Margaret Sanger the founder of Planned
Parenthood was a committed eugenicist -
explained quote to understand the
difficulties and the obstacles to be
overcome before the dream of a greater
race in America can be attained is to
understand something of the task before
the women who shall give birth to that
race among our more than 100 million
population are Negroes Indians Chinese
and other colored people - the number of
11 million
there are also 14 million 500,000
persons of foreign birth there were 1
million six hundred thousand illiterate
foreigners in the United States when the
1910 census was taken do these elements
give promise of a better race are we
doing anything genuinely constructive to
overcome this situation that's from her
book woman in the new race and they did
get very constructive reaching the
climax during roe v-- wade future
generations will look on our tolerance
of abortion with the same horror and
moral opprobrium
with which we view slaveholders in the
antebellum south which side will that
history record you as having taken